[Musik]
in einem wunderschönen land vor gar
nicht allzu langer zeit wo der eine
autorin sehr bekannt von der sprach bald
alles weit und breit und diese autorin
die ich meine nennt sich maja meyer
linde ihre ökologischen generationen
romane die geschichte der bienen und nun
auch die geschichte des wassers sind
welt- bestseller
ich bin sehr froh sie heute zum ersten
mal im deutschsprachigen fernsehen
begrüßen zu dürfen herzlich willkommen
freund der aus norwegen
warum heißen sie maria warum wurde in
dieser name von den eltern gegeben
nun damals in den 19 siebziger jahren
suchten sie einfach einen originellen
namen meinen verwandten zb meinen
großeltern gefühl man ja überhaupt nicht
denn damals nannte man mädchen nicht so
und ich wusste meine name weil nur alte
frauen so hießen
doch heute ist der name populär
wenn ich auf dem spielplatz bin höre ich
dass viele mädchen maja gerufen werden
ich glaube meine eltern wählten den
namen wegen seiner bedeutung in der
griechischen mythologie heißt die mutter
von atlas meyer
und natürlich kommt der name auch in
allen religionen vor
das ist jetzt tatsächlich so im
hebräischen und arabischen heißt maria
quelle
und es gibt andere motto kreise in denen
es schöpfer göttin heißt das scheint ja
sehr gut zu ihnen zu passen als kreativ
quelle und schöpfer könnte ja sie haben
ja in den letzten drei jahren eine
erfahrung gemacht die wenige menschen
und auch weniger autoren machen sie sind
praktisch über nacht zu einer welt-
bestseller autorin geworden
ihr buch die geschichte der bienen ist
in deutschland das meistverkaufte buch
des letzten jahres
wie erklären sie sich diesen erfolg
diesen fantastischen erfolg weltweit für
mich ist es irgendwie so wäre es fällt
mir schwer eine erklärung dafür zu
finden
ich weiß nicht warum das so ist als ich
die geschichte der bienen schrieb war
ich in einer art blase
ich dachte an jemanden wie schrieb
einfach das buch das ich lesen wollte
ich wusste nicht ob andere sich auch für
bienen interessieren und dann wurde das
buch plötzlich zum bestseller
der grund ist vielleicht das sagt mir
zumindest die leser dass das buch auf
verschiedenen ebenen
es sind recht emotionale geschichten von
eltern und ihren kindern dann geht es
natürlich um die bienen viele entdeckten
etwas neues in der welt dass sie vorher
nicht beachtet haben sie sehen und
verstehen dass sich das klima ändert
dass unsere umweltprobleme licht einfach
abstrakte vorgänge in der atmosphäre
sind sondern in ihrem garten passieren
das wurde auch mir bewusst als ich die
geschichte schrieb
die plötzlich all die in serie in der
natur
diese kleinen lebewesen die ich vorher
nicht wirklich beachtet hatte diese
faszination erklärt wohl auch den erfolg
des buches eine weise sich zu erklären
warum ein buch so ein erfolg hat einen
globalen erfolg ist natürlich auch das
in der lage ist zentrale sehnsüchte und
ängste der menschheit zu aktivieren zu
besprechen und bei ihnen sind es
letztlich ängste eines ökologischen
zusammenbruchs eines kollapses würden
sie dem zustimmen
wahrscheinlich stimmt ich kann nur sagen
was mir die leser mitteilen
einige empfinden das so andere sagen mir
sie hätten den roman verschlungen die
ganze nacht durch gelesen dass sich die
geschichte so leicht lesen lässt ist
wohl auch teil des erfolgs das hat
einerseits diese leser qualitäten das
ist sehr leicht zu lesen es andererseits
gibt es zentrale fragen unserer heutigen
existenz in form einer geschichte wider
und eine ist die frage nach dem
verhältnis von mensch und tier
und sie haben sich ein ganz besonderes
verhältnis ausgesucht nämlich das
verhältnis von mensch und honigbiene wie
würden sie dieses verhältnis beschreiben
ich denke bienen haben uns immer
fasziniert und seit tausenden von jahren
sammeln die menschen haftet etwas
magisches an
so empfand ich es als ich begann mich in
die materie zu vertiefen
denn ich wusste vorher nichts über
bienen
ich musste mir zuerst alles aneignen ich
war total fasziniert über das leben im
bienenstock wie komplex diese kleinen
insekten sind wie sie miteinander
kommunizieren
sie tanzen zum beispiel um einander
mitzuteilen wo güter nektar zu finden
ist sie arbeiten alle für die
gemeinschaft für das bienenvolk nicht
für sich selber das finde ich auch etwas
schönes
die magie des bienenstocks hat mich beim
schreiben beeinflusst
ich wollte in ihm drin sein und alles
verstehen auch wenn es sehr komplex ist
wir werden über diese faszination des
lebens der bienen noch noch viel länger
sprechen
aber was ein ein schritt zurück an bin
fasziniert ist ja dass sie eine seltsame
zwischen stein zwischen status haben sie
sind wilde tiere aber auch haustiere
sie sind in gewisser weise kultiviert
aber trotzdem den menschen nicht
untertan
sie sind fast so etwas wie unser
verhältnis zur natur als tier
wir versuchen ständig die natur zu
zählen
aber manchmal schlägt sie zurück ich
denke daher wir müssen lernen sie zu
motivieren den zähnen können wir sie
nicht so sehr wir es auch versuchen vor
allem die bienen zeigen uns dass wir
nicht alles richtig machen es gibt ein
sehr berühmtes buch über ein verhältnis
von mensch und tier von saint exupery
der kleine prinz und da gibt es einen
kleinen fuchs und der fuchs sagt du
musst mich zählen das ist das was die
bienen wahrscheinlich niemals sagen
würden und sagen können
nein das werden sie nicht sie wollen
nicht gezähmt werden
sie wollen einfach so leben wie sie es
immer getan haben wenn sie sagen das
leben der biene zu faszinieren wir haben
hier einen gläsernen bienenstock im
studio die bienen arbeiten jetzt sie
gehen ihrer tätigkeit nach man sieht ja
zunächst einmal dass das extrem dass das
extrem soziale tiere sind die sich gerne
verbannen einen haufen bilden ihre
individualität abgeben könnte man sagen
was tun sie und wie ich vorhin erwähnt
habe arbeiten sie für das gemeinwohl
sie tun das was den bienen folgt es ist
ein sehr komplexes zusammen schon ihr
summen zu hören macht mich glücklich
seitdem ich das buch geschrieben habe
bemühe ich mich deshalb keine bienen
oder andere insekten zu töten was bin
natürlich hier sehen ist ein wunderbares
beispiel für natur
es ist aber auch ein wunderbares
beispiel für kultur
denn dieses gegen haus das wir hier
sehen ist ja menschenwerk
es ist ein haus von menschen für bienen
gemacht das heißt so wie die bienen
eigentlich leben eigentlich leben gäbe
es diese form der sozialität und das
handelns gar nicht denn sie tun hier
praktisch das gleiche wie in der natur
wir erstellen bienenstöcke und züchten
bienenköniginnen weil wir bienen
brauchen aber sie müssen nichts anderes
tun als das was sie normalerweise in der
natur tun
das ist das gute am bienenstock
er ist der natur nachgebaut das ist also
praktisch ein perfect match kann man
sagen zwischen den bedürfnissen eines
tieres und den bedürfnissen des menschen
die im bienenstock ihren schönsten
ausdruck
das könnte man sagen in den modernen
großstädten können wir sogar honig
gewinnen ohne den bienen zu schaden
früher ging das nicht aber heute ist es
möglich was gut ist
[Musik]
jetzt hat diese nutzung der honigbiene
speziell die honigbiene ist ja nur einer
von etwa 600 bienenarten beispielsweise
im deutschsprachigen raum
die industrielle nutzung der bienen
große probleme
und wie groß diese probleme sind ja auch
im zentrum ihres ersten romans stehen
das schauen wir das jetzt in einem
ausschnitt aus einem dokumentarfilm von
markus imhof morden hanni kurzem ein
berg den ich stehe mit dem rücken lag
ich mit dem zurück was ich habe
[Musik]
nach dem stress der reise werden die
bienen aufgeführt mit zucker wasser
vermischt mit antibiotika und ganz
europa nordamerika und china kann heute
keine honigbiene mehr ohne medikamente
überleben
er vollendet das hat sich einiges was
vielleicht für unser verhältnis zur
ökologie an sich radikale oder
beispielhaft ist diese wander völker
werden durch den menschen durch die
lande gekarrt sie werden gedopte mit
antibiotika und zucker wasser um etwas
zu tun was sie sonst in dieser weise
auch getan hätten
jaja so organisieren wir unseren
planeten
das ist beängstigend werde ich solche
dokumentarfilme sehe habe ich den wunsch
etwas dagegen zu tun
das war einer der filme die ich mir
anschaute als ich begann führt die
geschichte der bienen zu recherchieren
eigentlich kam mir die idee zum roman
als ich diesen film schaut es war so der
film von marcus in hof der letztlich am
ursprung dieses buches steht kann man
sagen dass sie inspiriert wurden von
einem kunstwerk und dass ihr kunstwerk
auch inspirieren will zu handlungen dass
es vielleicht sogar eine form sagen wir
von engagierter literatur ist ja das
könnte man sagen
faszinierend ist wie einzelne teile
aufeinander aufbauen und zu etwas
heranwachsen und nun verbietet die eu
die mio
wie heißt schon wieder der ausdruck ja
ich bin stolz dass ich ein wenig dazu
beitragen konnte tatsächlich wie
natürlich auch dieser film tatsächlich
wurden vor einem monat eu-weit gewisse
intensität die in verdacht stehen dieses
bienensterben zu befördern
gebannt sie würden sagen das ist für sie
ein erfolg vielleicht sogar auch ein
persönlicher fort ich denke die
bestrebungen die zu diesem verbot
führten begannen schon vor dem
erscheinen meines buches und waren in
europa sehr erfolgreich aber ich finde
es gut dass sich auch ein wenig dazu
beitragen konnte
dennoch hat dieser industrielle imker
einsatz gesagt der mir sehr zu denken
gibt er sagt wir wissen nicht woher es
kommt also schlage ich mit den waffen
zurück die ich habe und diese waffen
sind chemische waffen und so handeln wir
immer wir meinen chemische mittel und
neue technologien würden helfen anstatt
dass wir frühere lösungsansätze prüfen
was zumindest manchmal zu einer antwort
führen könnte mein vorteil als autorin
ist dass ich nicht ständig antworten
liefern muss ich kann einfach fragen
stellen
zum glück bin ich nicht politikerin denn
viele meiner fragen könnte ich gar nicht
beantworten ich möchte weiterhin einfach
fragen stellen und diese probleme auf
meine weise angehen
mit literatur und fiktion denn das hier
ist bestimmt keine sachliteratur
das stimmt sehr kunstvolle weise zeigen
sie aber auch etwas auf was man eine
reise des bienen
unseres umgangs mit bienen nehmen könnte
in einem rahmen von 250 jahren etwa vom
19 jahrhundert bis in die zukunft hinein
als jahr 2090 zeigen sie die
kultivierung und die domestizierung der
bild der bienen ihr aussterben und dann
leben wir in einer zeit einer
dystopischen zeit der zukunft in denen
menschen tun müssen was bienen tun
nämlich bäume bestäuben und das ist
etwas was vielleicht die ganze
menschheit gar nicht leisten könnte wenn
sie es denn tun müsste ich habe china im
jahr 2098 als handlungsort für meine
geschichte ausgewählt weil die chinesen
in der provinz sichuan bereits bäume von
hand bestäubt in den 1980 er jahren
starben dort durch pestizide alle bienen
daher waren die leute gezwungen auf die
bäume zu klettern und sie von hand zu
bestäuben
das war erfolgreich und sie fuhren damit
fort obwohl die beiden sich wieder
erholten und teilweise zurückkehrten
[Musik]
im internet gibt es faszinierende und
schöne wenn auch beängstigende bilder
aus china von leuten die auf bäume
klettern und die blüten von hand
bestäuben es ist eine andere art die
natur zu kontrollieren
und es ist ein gutes beispiel dafür wie
wir das auf der ganzen welt tun
heute spricht man sogar über künstliche
bienen die übernehmen sollen was die
natur sonst tut wir menschen neigen dazu
zu glauben wir hätten für alles eine
lösung
wir könnten einfach technologien
einsetzen und damit das tun was bisher
die natur gemacht hat für mich ist das
seltsam und es macht mir auch angst
margrit ihr sagen es gibt zwei lösungen
dafür eine homo faber lösung dafür der
technisierte menschen noch heute sagen
was die bienen machen machen in zukunft
drohnen das kleine micro drogen die
werden dass noch viel präziser machen
wir brauchen die bienen gar nicht mehr
in ihren roman aber ist immer etwas
passiert es gibt eine art kollaps der
menschheit die technologie versagt sie
funktionieren nicht mehr
und der mensch ist zurückgeworfen auf
das elementare verhältnis von natur und
mensch ja meine geschichte oder besser
meine geschichten denn ich arbeite an
einem vierteiler der zweite teil die
geschichte des wassers mit dem
originaltitel blau ist gerade erschienen
sie ist im gleichen universum
angesiedelt die geschichte der bienen
spielt im jahr 2098 in der vergangenheit
und in der gegenwart
die geschichte des wassers spiel 2041
also ein paar jahre vor dem kollaps der
natur den ich in die geschichte des
wassers beschreibe aber es betrifft die
gleiche zukunft zwei weitere geschichten
sind geplant die schreiben momentan an
der dritten und alle vier sind
miteinander verbunden
darüber kann ich später mehr sagen aber
in allem geht es um die gleiche zukunft
und alle menschen sind davon betroffen
denn durch den kollaps 2045 verschwinden
fast alle bestäubenden insekten auf der
erde
das hat natürlich massive auswirkungen
die moderne welt wie wir sie kennen gibt
es nicht mehr
die menschen müssen so hart arbeiten
damit sie genug zu essen haben dass
ihnen keine zeit bleibt neue großartige
technologien zu erfinden
es ist also eine post technologische
gesellschaft gut ist dass mir das nicht
bewusst war als ich
geschichte spielt ich sah mich nie als
autorin von science fiction romanen oder
dystopien ich schreibe einfach romane
für mich war es anfangs schwierig mich
in diese zukunft zu versetzen
ich meinte dann brauchen die menschen
alle möglichen coolen geräte
doch mir wurde klar in der von mir
beschriebenen zukunft ist das anders sie
haben keine zeit dafür
all die florierenden unternehmen gibt es
nicht mehr wir sind also im post
technologisches zeitalter
das ist so interessant weil jede
generation hat ihre eigene dystopie und
als wir beide wir sind ja wahrscheinlich
1970 um die 175 geboren da war die große
dystopie der atomschlag der die gesamte
menschheit in einen stein zeitung
erbringt jetzt scheint sich das
gewandelt zu haben und ihr buch spricht
dafür
wir brauchen keine atomare katastrophe
mehr wir führen den krieg gegen die
natur mittlerweile selbst und es wird
eine ähnliche katastrophe entstehen wenn
sie denn sagen dass das was wir derzeit
in der westlichen welt tun eine art
krieg gegen unsere lebensgrundlagen ist
krieg ist ein starkes wort dafür
ich habe nicht den eindruck wir werden
kämpfen
das größte problem ist vielmehr unsere
passivität krieg wäre etwas aktives
aber unsere probleme resultieren alle
daraus dass wir zu wenig tun so sie
würden sagen ist es eher eine form von
passivität und blindheit in einer
aktivität weil wenn ich ihre bücher lese
und das ist sehr faszinierend dass es
immer die vision einer all verbundenheit
zwischen allen lebenden dingen zwischen
den generationen und zwischen der natur
es ist so als ob sie eine komplexität
freilegen wollen die immer da ist deren
wir uns aber nicht bewusst sind dass sie
das so lesen
ich denke wir vergessen auf das alles
miteinander verbunden ist was wir sie
und ich zu hause tun wie wir unsere
kinder behandeln wie wir mit der umwelt
umgehen ist teil eines größeren ganzen
alles was wir tun und natürlich auch was
wir nicht tun was wir kaufen wohin wir
fliegen
all das ist teil dieses größeren ganzen
globus besteht aus kleinen einzelteilen
dazu gehören die bienen sie sind die
kleinsten und wir hängen alle
voneinander ab bevor wir also dinge
ändern können sollte uns bewusst sein
dass es gut ist uns als teil dieses
größeren ganzen zu sehen
es ist so interessant was sie sagen und
ist versehen der gedanke einerseits kann
man sagen wir erleben das größte
artensterben seit der auslöschung der
dinosaurier
vielleicht dieses artensterben ist von
menschen bewirkt
andererseits sagen sie ein krieg ist das
eigentlich nicht ist eine form von
passivität es gibt in ihrem zweiten buch
die geschichte des wassers eine kurze
referenz zu hannah arendt und der
konzept der banalität des bösen
würden sie sagen dass unsere
gleichgültigkeit gegen die zerstörung
die eine ganz alltägliche ist eine
banalität des bösen im sinne ahrens ist
ich denke wir wollen nicht banal und
gedankenlos seien aber viele geben
einfach auf wir wissen nicht wo wir
beginnen sollen
oder wir haben den eindruck wir könnten
als einzelne person nichts bewirken
wir alle können so denken auch ich
ertappe mich an manchen tagen dabei doch
beim schreiben dieses buches realisierte
ich dass wir etwas verändern können
jeder von uns kann kleine änderungen
bewirken in der nachbarschaft oder zu
hause das ist gar nicht so schwer
und wenn wir alle im kleinen dinge
verändern anstatt ignorant und passiv zu
sein hilft das schon denn die welt ist
durch kleine nicht durch große
veränderungen entstanden und das ist
etwas positives sich einzusetzen können
glücklich und stolz machen dass man
daran beteiligt ist die welt ein klein
wenig besser zu machen
dennoch ist es ja auch pädagogisch sie
haben drei söhne jüngeren alters relativ
heikel oder schwierig einerseits die
größe des problems sichtbar zu machen
und zu sagen was da eigentlich passiert
und andererseits nicht zustände der
verzweiflung der angst unter aufgabe zu
erzeugen würden sie ihren söhnen ist das
auch ein buch an ihre söhne wo sie sagen
ich versuche euch zu zeigen wie groß das
problem ist aber auch dass man mit
kleinen aktionen etwas lösen kann weil
man könnte jetzt einen kleinen aktion
werden uns nicht helfen kleine aktionen
sind zu klein für dieses große problem
ich glaube wenn man mit kindern über
dieses thema spricht muss man ihnen die
wahrheit sagen
sie wissen bereits bescheid
so nimmt es die norwegen sprechen sie in
der schule darüber und ich denke hier
der schweiz ist das auch der fall
sie lernen es und sie wollen es wissen
denn es betrifft ihre zukunft es bringt
also nichts ihnen etwas zu verschweigen
aber man muss sich auf das positive
konzentrieren darauf was man in der
eigenen familie machen kann und was sie
tun können wenn sie größer sind
ich denke so muss man es angehen darüber
sprechen und das positive heraus
streichen
es ist interessant ich will das nicht so
persönlich machen aber in meinem
kinderzimmer hing damals ein poster mit
einem atompilz auf dem stand no future
das war die zeit der friedensbewegung
und der atomaren angst und ich würde
sagen dass ich doch auch mit dem
bewusstsein aufgewachsen bin dass es
sofort vorbei sein kann dass ein
atomschlag das leben in meinem land
unter auslöst und das ist nicht
unbedingt etwas was kinder ernst nehmen
würden sie denn wirklich sagen sagt den
kindern genau wie groß das problem ist
und die negativen effekte die sind
kleiner als das was sie vielleicht zum
handeln bewegt auf jeden fall
das sollte man ihnen aufzeigen und ihnen
sagen vielleicht fragst du dieses neue
plastikspielzeug nicht denn es gibt auf
der welt bereits zu viel plastik das
können kinder verstehen und
nachvollziehen es ist besser als einfach
nein zu sagen oder ihnen mehr spielzeuge
zu schenken als sie eigentlich brauchen
ich finde kinder können das so gut
verstehen wie erwachsene zudem sehr
wichtig dass sie die natur liegen lernen
dass man mit ihnen nach draußen geht
ihnen die natur nahe bringt und zeigt
wie alles teil des großen puzzles ist
wir sollten also auf jeden fall mit
unseren kindern darüber sprechen aber
sicher dürfen wir sie nicht verängstigen
ähnlich wie sie bin ich aufgewachsen mit
einem poster in der küche auf dem stand
nuklearwaffen nein danke oder so ähnlich
das war eine große sache ich weiß noch
dass ich angst hatte ich wusste wohin
ich rennen musste wenn es passieren
würde wenn der große schlag häme
wir hatten das geübt wir lebten ja auch
in der nähe von russlands der damaligen
sowjetunion die angst vor einem
atomkrieg war in den 1980 er jahren groß
doch hier geht es um etwas anderes etwas
woran sich kinder beteiligen können
sie können kleine änderungen bewirken
[Musik]
das ist weniger beängstigend als wenn
männer in schwarzen anzügen
entscheidungen über die zukunft der welt
und unser schicksal treffen weil es ist
ja ihre ökologischen generationenroman
also habe ich sie genannt sind ja auch
romaner über das problem der
sprachlosigkeit von generationen in
beiden büchern gibt es das problem dass
die eltern zu den kindern nach einer
sprache suchen und diese sprache nicht
finden ich denke viel kommunikation ist
wichtig in all meinen romanen
ich arbeite gerade mit hochdruck am
dritten buch meines zyklus und freue
mich sehr darauf dieses werk
fortzuführen
[Musik]
aber anscheinend komme ich immer wieder
auf dieses thema zurück die
kommunikation in der familie
die beziehung zwischen eltern und ihren
kindern
sie ist äußerst wichtig für alle die
geschichte der bienen handelt von bienen
aber das hauptthema ist die beziehung
zwischen eltern und ihren kindern auch
in die geschichte des wassers geht es um
diese beziehung aber es ist auch eine
liebesgeschichte
eigentlich sind es zwei
liebesgeschichten da finden sie also
auch romantische liebe aber es geht
immer um die beziehung zwischen menschen
um kommunikation
wenn ich schreibe entscheide ich nicht
was passieren wird
natürlich habe ich eine struktur und
überlege mir ein paar rott szenarien
durch beschreiben möchte ich habe einen
handlungsstrang um es technisch
auszudrücken aber dann passiert viel
während ich schreibe
[Musik]
am wichtigsten ist es für mich meinen
figuren gerecht zu werden
diese menschen kennenzulernen mich in
sie hineinzuversetzen
das ist meine hauptaufgabe wenn ich
schreibe
daher könnte ich keine sachbücher
schreiben ich finde es vor allem
faszinierend mich in meine figur
hineinzuversetzen und ich habe den
eindruck sie haben ein eigenleben
sie leben ihr leben diese autonomie des
charakters ist ja etwas worüber viele
schriftsteller sprechen ich könnte ihnen
das gar nicht sagen lassen
die sind helden war das gar nicht sagen
würde aber vielleicht werde ich nochmal
auf dieses schweigen das mich sehr
fasziniert zurückkomme wenn man ein
bisschen interpretieren aber irgendwie
passiert das ständig meine figuren haben
immer kommunikationsprobleme mit ihren
kindern
obwohl ich eine recht gute beziehung zu
meinen eigenen eltern
und dass die frage ist ja manchmal ist
der grund für ein tiefes schweigen über
die generation eine tiefe schuld glauben
sie denn dass man sagen könnte
eigentlich haben wir eine tiefe schuld
gegenüber unseren kindern die jetzt auf
die welt geworfen werden
aufgrund der tatsache dass wir ihn so
eine welt überlassen
nun das ist eine traurige sichtweise
manchmal fühle ich mich vielleicht
schuldig aber ich bin auch sehr
glücklich wenn ich meinen kindern den
wundervollen planeten auf dem wir leben
zeigen kann
[Musik]
behring sind wir der natur nein sie ist
so sehr teil unserer identität
ich lebe ausserhalb von oslo
aber ich bin nur zwölf minuten mit der
u-bahn im zentrum der stadt und zu fuß
bin ich in fünf minuten im wald so klein
ist oslo
wir haben auch all die fjorde
das betrifft ganz norwegen wir sind der
natur sehr nahe
sie ist daher ein wichtiger teil unserer
identität das ist meine positive
sichtweise
ich gehe mit meinen kindern gerne nach
draußen zeigen ihnen alle wunder der
welt und die sind meistens in der natur
in norwegen sind natürlich ganz
beträchtlich man kann sogar sagen dass
norwegen fast den lebensstandard
betreffen derzeit die führende nation
auf diesem planeten gibt es gibt keine
gesünderen klügeren und besorgten kinder
als in norwegen aber es gibt einen
ökologisch dunklen aspekt dieses
wohlstandes sie schreiben dass auch in
ihrem zweiten buch las er seinen
charakter sagen dass dieser reichtum und
der wohlfahrtsstaat norwegens ökologisch
in gewisser weise auf naturressourcen
ausbeutung beruht auf
öl und gas ist das etwas was in ihrer
gesellschaft in norwegen stark
diskutiert wird das im prinzip ihr
wohlstand ökologisch nicht nachhaltig
ist
darüber sprechen wir viel
es könnte aber noch mehr thematisiert
werden finde ich die politiker die wir
gerade neu gewählt haben wollen die
natur noch mehr ausbeuten
sie wollen noch mehr öl und gas fördern
was ich verrückt finde und zwar in
vielerlei hinsicht wir sind maßgeblich
daran beteiligt dass die temperaturen
weltweit steigen
das ist ein riesiges problem für uns und
den ganzen planeten und wir haben damit
so viel geld verdient es ist daher
höchste zeit dass wir das geld in grüne
energie anstatt ihn noch mehr öl
investieren
ich wünschte mir sehr dass wir einen weg
finden um diesen überfluss in die
entwicklung grüner energien zu stecken
ich habe auch den eindruck dass ich in
der welt diesbezüglich einiges tut es
ist fantastisch wie viele solar und
windenergie projekte es gibt man hat den
eindruck alle hätten verständnis dafür
außer den norwegischen politikern die
weiter öl fördern wollen wie in den 1980
er jahren in den 80er jahren da gab es
einspruch der wahl politisch sehr
wichtig wir haben die welt nur von
unseren kindern geborgt das mantra der
grünen bewegung in ganz europa würden
sie denn sagen das stimmt wir haben die
welt nur von unseren kindern geborgt wir
haben sie nur gebaut
das weiß jeder bauer wenn er seinen hof
an seinen sohn oder seine tochter
vererbt sollte er in einem besseren
zustand seien als zu der zeit
als er ihn übernommen hatte er will den
für seine kinder also etwas verbessern
doch so handeln wir nicht wir machen
dinge schlechter ich bin mal sagen was
mich an dieser formulierung als
philosoph oder philosophierender stört
denn das borgen einer welt für die
kinder heißt ja auch dass die welt uns
schon gehört es positioniert den
menschen schon als einen inhaber von
einer natur
wäre es nicht besser zu sagen wir haben
die welt nicht in seiner geburt sondern
sie gehört uns überhaupt nicht das
stimmt ich stelle mir auch solche fragen
denn wir sind nur teil der natur uns
gehört gar nichts und wir sollten dafür
sorgen dass die lebensbedingungen besser
und nicht schlechter werden für alle
arten auf diesem schiff nun könnte man
ja sagen der mensch ist ein relativ
kurzlebiger art in 250 millionen jahren
wird es ihnen vermutlich gar nicht mehr
geben so wie es ihn vor 250 millionen
jahren nicht mehr geht die evolution
wird ihren gang gehen die idee dass wir
die umwelt schützen müssen es eigentlich
gar nicht sinnvoll die umwelt wird das
schon selber regeln wir sollten es tun
weil wir es können weil wir intelligent
genug sind und weil wir genug weise sind
um zu sehen dass unser einfluss unser
fußabdruck auf der welt sehr groß ist
[Musik]
deshalb sollten wir verantwortung
übernehmen
wir sind das mächtigste tier auf unserem
planeten und wehrmacht hat muss auch
viel verantwortung übernehmen
damit sollten ich habe einmal mit einem
autoren liegen gesprochen johnson
frentzen der auch amerikanischer oder
der sehr viel über ökologie schreibt und
die frage an ihn war ob der erde als
system ohne den menschen nicht besser
dran wäre
ob man sich als mensch nicht eigentlich
gmünd mit wünschen müsste dass wir dann
gar nicht mehr da sind ist das ein
wunsch den sie verstehen den sie
nachvollziehen können nächsten tagen in
verstehe ich das jetzt wenn ich gefragt
werde ob ich ein positiv oder negativ
denkender mensch bin sage ich ich denke
manchmal positiv und manchmal negativ an
meine negativen tagen kann ich das
verstehen
trotzdem finde ich der mensch ist ein so
wunderbares tier was wir alles tun
können unsere fähigkeit
zusammenzuarbeiten ist wirklich
wunderbar auch die menschliche liebe die
liebe zwischen menschen ist etwas sehr
schönes oder unsere vorstellungskraft
und kreativität
das sind wunderbare eigenschaften ich
glaube also wirklich an uns ein
wunderbares beispiel dessen was menschen
auch technisch leisten können das sehen
wir uns jetzt auf einem foto an das ist
nämlich das erste foto das aus dem
weltraum von der gesamten erde genommen
wurde von apollo 1 dieses bild auch ein
wunderwerk menschlicher ingenio sieht ja
was fällt ihnen ein wenn sie dieses bild
sehen
als ich die geschichte des lasters
schrieb habe ich mir viele solche bilder
angeschaut denn auf norwegisch heißt der
roman glaubt unter anderem welt ich
diesen titel
eine der figuren über die farbe des
planeten nachdenkt und findet er sei
blau wenn man ihn von weitem betrachtet
zwei drittel von mehr bedrückt nicht
wahr
tatsächlich er ist der blaue planet und
sollte auch so heißen
der planet erde als blau
dennoch wurde ihr buch als die
geschichte des wassers übersetzt und es
handelt von einer situation der
wasserknappheit in der zukunft die auch
zu einer flüchtlingskrise führt menschen
aus südfrankreich sehnen sich danach in
die wasser reichen länder des nordens zu
flüchten
jetzt kann man sagen das ist ein
szenario dass sie mich weit weg dass man
kann auch sagen das ist das szenario das
wir jetzt haben nur dass wir
mitteleuropa durch den mittleren osten
übersetzen und wir haben jetzt schon
wasser flüchtlinge ja diese situation
erleben wir schon heute als ich klima
berichte und zukunftsszenarien studierte
war das was ich las sehr bedrückend denn
es wird immer wärmer und wenn es uns
nicht gelingt die globale erwärmung zu
stoppen wird das leben im süden von
europa schwierig werden bezüglich der
wetterentwicklung sind sich die experten
einig dass wir zukünftig erleben was sie
bereits heute kennen nur extreme in
norwegen haben wir zum beispiel viel
reden
es wird also in zukunft noch mehr regnen
stürmen und winden die extreme steigern
sich in jeder beziehung ja und in den
südlichen teilen europas werden die
sommer noch wärmer und es wird mehr
dürren geben
[Musik]
in meinem szenario gibt es eine sehr
lange heizperiode
5 jahre fest ohne
europa ist gewissermaßen kollabiert die
grenzen sind geschlossen
wir haben ein internes
flüchtlingsproblem meine hauptfigur ist
ein flüchtling ein junger vater der aus
südfrankreich flieht und in einem
flüchtlingslager in der nähe von
bordeaux strand seine geschichte
widerspiegelt die heutige weltweite
situation der flüchtlinge die nach
europa kommen
es gibt dort auch eine umweltaktivistin
in diesem buch segne und diese aktivist
ist wenn man sich in norwegen ein
bisschen auskennt vielleicht eine
nachfolgerin eines sehr berühmten
philosophen in norwegen den 70er jahren
einer philosophie entwickelt hat die dpg
heißt das doch ein umweltaktivist und er
ist jemand der glaube ich ihre ganze
generation und ihr denken über die
umwelt sehr geprägt hat wie würden sie
den einfluss von annes ökologischem
denken auf sie selbst beschreiben
seltsam ist das ahnen es in anderen
ländern viel berühmter ist als in
norwegen
ich denke dieses phänomen beobachtet man
in vielen ländern ja aber was meine
figur sinne betrifft handelt ihre
geschichte im heutigen norwegen
doch sie denkt viel an früher
sie ist 1950 geboren und erinnert sich
an die jahre die sie zur person gemacht
haben die sie ist in ihrem dorf gab es
einen großen konflikt wegen dem
schmelzen der gletscher und der
entwicklung von wasserkraftwerken
[Musik]
deswegen gab es in norwegen in den 19
70er 80er und 90er jahren viele
konflikte damals wurden an unseren
flüssen viele elektrizitätswerke gebaut
wir haben fast keine natürlichen flüsse
mehr und wir sind wahrscheinlich dass
fluss reichste land der welt
wir haben in norwegen viel wasser war
teil dieser bewegung und singe gehört
auch dazu sie geht oft demonstrieren
sie ist stark beeinflusst von gandhi
doch sie wird immer extremer
während die deep ecology philosophie von
ahnen es positiv ist wird sie immer
aggressiver
sie ist nicht unbedingt eine positive
person und daher eine sehr interessante
figur für mich als schriftstellerin
zwanghaft extremistisch auch schwer
ungerecht kann man sagen ja interessant
an diesem arne nächstes danken der dpg
ist für mich ja dass er sagt wir sollten
die natur nicht als eine ressource
schützen wie es beispielsweise dass
nachhaltigkeit denken tut sondern wir
sollten erkennen dass die natur keine
ressource ist sondern etwas das auch da
ist und durch die ganzen verbindungen in
denen wir stehen einen eigenwert hat und
auch eigenständig gestützte sind also
nicht als ressource für uns sondern an
sich ist das auch was was sie denken
würden die natur ist nicht für uns
nachhaltig zu schützen sondern sich zu
schützen weil sie da ist ja ich stimme
in viele meckern über ein noch nicht in
allem die vertreter der dpg philosophie
die natur habe ihren eigenen wert und
wir sollten uns als teil des größeren
ganzen sehen
das ist eine sehr gute sicht
wer die welt so sieht der versteht
besser dass änderungen nötig sind
[Musik]
denn das bedürfnis die natur auszubeuten
stark in uns verwurzelt das haben wir
immer getan
wir waren davon abhängig doch jetzt ist
es höchste zeit sie zu beschützen
denn ein pinguin hat zb gleich viel wert
wie sie und ich
er ist ein lebewesen wie wir
warum sollten wir ihn nicht schützen das
können wir es klingt einerseits sehr
plausible und gut zu sagen ein pinguin
hat den gleichen wert wären menschen
aber wenn sie einen jungen pinguin ein
junges baby sehen und sie können nur
eins von beiden retten würden sie kaum
den pinguin nehmen natürlich nicht da
muss man realistisch sein um wieder auf
die eltern-kind-beziehung zurückzukommen
die liebe die wir für unsere kinder
empfinden ist bestimmt die stärkste
liebe die es gibt
ich würde sicher mein leben geben für
eines meiner kinder rein instinktiv wir
sind ja tiere deshalb ist das natürlich
natürlich auch unser körper ist fast
noch gleich wie vor zehntausenden jahren
darüber müssen wir unbedingt sprechen
wir handeln aufgrund unserer instinkte
wir reagieren auf unsere biologischen
impulse
die kann man schlecht ignorieren wenn
sie zum beispiel einkaufen gehen ist ihr
alter sammler instinkt aktiv sie wollen
beeren sammeln die gleichen dinge laufen
im gehirn ab ob sie einkaufen oder
beeren sammeln dass die shopping mall
ein riesiges bären fällt ist das niemals
aufhört was mehr zu einem weiteren
aspekt ihres denkens die sprachen von
instinkten von unserer körperlichkeit
und man kann aus ihren büchern auch
herauslesen dass sie eine verbindung
zwischen feminismus und ökologie sehen
die frauengestalten haben ein sehr
starkes verantwortungsgefühl mutter erde
gegenüber
beim schreiben passiert ich habe mich
nie bewusst dafür entschieden
wie gesagt ich möchte meinen figuren
gerecht werden als ich die geschichte
der bienen schrieb waren mir meine drei
hauptfiguren von anfang an klar
auch die geschichte des wassers begann
für mich mit den figuren mit dem jungen
flüchtling und dem vater der allein für
seine kleine tochter verantwortlich ist
und mit der umweltaktivisten ich hatte
ein klares bild von ihr in meinem kopf
sie ist eine alte frau wenn auch nicht
so alt wie in der ersten geschichte
da war sie sehr alt eine alte frau die
in norwegen nahe an einem wasserfall
lebt ist sehr stark
sie ist aktivistin david der
französische flüchtling ist sehr besorgt
um seine mitmenschen und um die natur
fast mehr als singe dir echt extrem ist
meine figuren sind also nicht schwarz
oder weiß
aber ich habe tatsächlich ein paar
starke frauen in meinen geschichten
innerhalb dieses ökologischen diskurses
aus dem sie ja auch viele gedanken
ziehen gibt es aber doch schon die idee
dass das verhältnis der unterdrückung
die den mann zur frau ausmacht ein
verhältnis ist das ähnlich ist der
unterdrückung von man und natur oder
mensch und natur
also würden sie sagen dass wir um ein
ökologisches bewusstsein entwickeln zu
können auch ein feministisches
bewusstsein brauchen es ist sicher nötig
dass frauen weltweit mehr rechte
bekommen
wir sind schon weit gekommen vor allem
in afrika aber wir haben immer noch
einen weiten weg vor uns
das wird die welt auf gute weise
beeinflussen
ich würde also sagen ja aber ich bin
weniger extrem als die öko feministinnen
für mich ist es nicht das wichtigste
thema meiner literatur
ich habe einfach eine tendenz über
starke frauen zu schreiben wenn wir uns
diese erde untertan gemacht haben
für die letzten 10.000 jahre unseres
unseres daseins dann zeigt sich da auch
eine seltsame beschleunigung eine
beschreibung die sich sogar auch in
ihren büchern zeigt das erste ist 250
jahre gespannt das andere ist nur noch
50 jahre gespannt in den verheerungen
die der mensch anrichtet glauben sie
dass diese zeithorizonte auch etwas sind
was uns als natürliche menschen
überfordert dass wir uns nicht
vorstellen können diese welt in 30
jahren zu zerstören obwohl wir es ja
fast tun und gerade im begriff sind das
die zeitlichkeit selbst etwas ist was zu
schnell geht es heißt ja dass ihr
menschen mühe haben weit in die zukunft
sehen wir können uns nicht mehr als die
nächsten 30 jahre vorstellen
es gelingt uns schlecht so visualisieren
was nachher passieren könnte
es bleibt diese ungewissheit deshalb
schreibe ich romane
es muss unglaublich schwierig seien
reale szenarien zu entwerfen
trotzdem recherchiere ich viel und
versuche so realistisch wie möglich zu
sein
aber wir wissen es einfach nicht heute
entwickelt sich die technologie so
schnell manche meinen sie sei die lösung
für alles aber wenn ich meine
abhängigkeit vom smartphone sehe wünsche
ich mir manchmal die technologie würde
sich selber vernichten
aber der breiteste horizont den wir ganz
persönlich spüren ist die
familiengeschichte und diese
familiengeschichten die werden norwegen
doch würde ich sagen auch mehrere
hundert jahre zurückreichen das heißt
die familie ist vielleicht der breiteste
horizont und die geschichten der familie
geben uns eine idee wenigstens davon für
unsere kontinuität familien zu
beobachten zu sehen was in familien
passiert ist immer faszinierend
[Musik]
da gibt es geister wir alle haben unsere
geister und dinge die in früheren
generationen passiert sind können uns
noch heute stark beeinflussen
es können traumata seien die weiter
bestehen oder auch biologisch bedingte
geister dinge die wir geerbt haben wie
zb depressionen
[Musik]
auch aus diesem grund ist für mich als
schriftstellerin die familie eine
faszinierende struktur ein
faszinierender handlungsort
vor allem kinder faszinieren mich sehr
sie haben ja jetzt etwas ganz
ungewöhnlich getan sie haben zwei bücher
in die welt gesetzt die kinder sind die
sich ganz fantastisch entwickelt haben
es ist ja eine situation absehbar sie
schreiben noch zwei weitere bücher sie
sagen das ist ein zyklus in der sie so
etwas wie ein globales gesicht für
ökologische fragen werden in der sie
auch eine gewisse verantwortung haben
weil sie dieses gesicht sind ist das
etwas was sie interessiert oder was
ihnen eher furcht einflößt dass sie eine
der wichtigen stimmen auf diesem
planeten für globale fragen werden
könnten es gibt bereits so viele stimmen
wenn ich in diesem chor einstimmen kann
ist das etwas gutes
[Musik]
aber wenn ich schreibe ist es wichtig
für mich nicht an die leser zu denken
als ich die geschichte der bienen
schrieb war ich in einer art blase
da war nur ich und die geschichte als
ich dann die geschichte des wassers war
es schwieriger denn ich hatte den
eindruck die ganze welt schaue mir über
die schulter um zu sehen was ich jetzt
schreit aber ich muss in dieser blase
sein
ich muss das buch schreiben das ich
lesen möchte das klingt vielleicht ein
wenig egozentrisch
aber nur so kann ich das tun momentan
beim schreiben des dritten romans geht
es mir gleich
ich muss voll und ganz in die geschichte
eintauchen muss fühlen was die figuren
empfinden muss angst haben wenn sie sich
fürchten
das ist für mich das wichtigste
wenn ich dann damit an die
öffentlichkeit gehe und viele menschen
erreiche beginnt eine völlig andere
phase
dann wächst mein wunsch noch mehr zu
schreiben weiter zu fahren aber ich habe
auch buch projekte bei denen es nicht um
ökologie geht und die völlig anders sind
ich sehe mich in erster linie als roman
autorin
wenn mich leute als politisch oder
ökologisch bezeichnen wenn ich ihnen
nicht böse aber am wichtigsten für mich
ist das schreiben
eine letzte frage mit einer wert um eine
relativ kurze antwort ihre bücher bei
alterstypischen apokalyptischen kraft
enden immer mit einem hoffnungsschimmer
ist das für sie eine literarische
technik oder etwas woran sie wirklich
aus ihre person heraus glaube sie finden
sie enden hoffnungsvoll
ich habe mit vielen lesern gesprochen
die satten die geschichte des wassers
ende traurig das sagt auch etwas über
sie aus übersee das wäre auch
interessant und für kunst gar nicht und
ja es gibt so viele interpretationen
eines buchs wie leser das macht die
fiktion so faszinierend das gilt sicher
auch für ihre bücher ich bin sehr froh
dass sie heute hier waren bei einer
sendung bei der soweit ich weiß keine
tiere und auch keine gedanken zu schaden
gekommen sind
herzlichen dank dass sie da waren
frohlinde
morgen amt begrüßen wir sie auf sf2 zum
zweiten mal zu einer sternstunde zu
später uhrzeit wir fragen woher kommt
das böse steckt es in jedem von uns und
wieso kokettieren so viele menschen mit
den bösen auch nächsten sonntag geht es
um moralische grundfragen am
philosophischen stammtisch in basel
diskutiert meine kollegin barbara
bleisch mit weiteren philosophin und
philosophen die meetyoo debatte
die auszeichnung ist kommenden
mittwochabend falls sie live mit dabei
sein möchten es gibt auf unserer website
noch letzte tickets und jetzt gleich
begleitet die sternstunde kunst art brut
kunstschaffende die unterdessen auch an
ganz großen kunst events erfolg haben im
kunstbetrieb und in der gesellschaft
aber noch immer als ausrede gelten
vielen dank waren sie es gut
[Musik]
bei